ça c'est le lundi matin
l'équipe de la populaire émission
radiophonique à la semaine prochaine
pour fine les textes de la revue
humoristique de l'actualité qu'elle
présente chaque semaine nous passerons
la prochaine heure ensemble en compagnie
des gens qui ont marqué l'actualité de
l'année
le soir du 31 décembre à la semaine
prochaine devient à l'année prochaine
il est aussi diffusée à la télévision m
dos m dos c'est l'épisode le plus écouté
de la saison je tiens à remercier mon
équipe a ouais merci à barack obama de
m'avoir appuyé émergea dans notre
chambre de ne pas la voir faire alors je
me revois la fin cette année en raison
de la pandémie
l'animateur crois que l'émission hérite
d'une mission sociale on n'a même pas
droit de se voir ni à noël ni au jour de
l'an alors moi j'ose croire que le 31 il
va avoir beaucoup de personnes qui vont
regarder leur télévision pour se
détendre pour se distraire pour être
accompagné par quelqu'un règle veut que
les gens soient contents dans un studio
de radio canada
une équipe est en plein tournage de
l'émission la plus regardée de l'année
au pays
le bye bye c'est pour bientôt les gammes
serbe lui c'est moi le fantôme du canada
une tradition humoristique unique au
monde
vieille de 52 ans ce soir on a plusieurs
surprises pour toi pour moi avec plus de
4 millions de téléspectateurs
si l'émission la plus regardée de
l'année au pays
on est la seule activité officielle j'en
ai fait écouter mais yat-il place tahrir
cette année non les commentaires qu'on
soit des gens disent cette année plus
que jamais on a besoin d'eux on a besoin
de lakovic 19 continue d'engendrer
d'innombrables drame humain pas de doute
il faudra faire preuve de délicatesse
tout le monde avec une année difficile a
eu dix décennies des gens qui ont perdu
les entreprises j'ai toujours des
situations qui sont vraiment triste et
difficile accès sûr qu'on peut pas
arriver avec le bye bye le plus corrosif
depuis 50 ans passe sur le but on veut
vraiment faire un bye bye drôle et
rassemble et puis notre expérience
commune du confinement sert
d'inspiration
on a tous vécu au québec à peu près les
mêmes choses au même moment ils ont
fermé les écoles en même temps on s'est
mis à faire du pain en même temps et
plein de choses qui sont arrivées
deviennent des référents puis pour un
bye bye se suspendent le fait qu'à rodez
giuliani est attrapé la commune à
l'année prochaine
évitera de se moquer de certaines
personnes il y a aussi les ch et celle
des les résidences pour aînés devenu le
symbole de l'hécatombe causée par ce
virus partant son personnage et faire
attention aux infirmières fera quand son
personnage je fais pas de sketches os
hausse des achats soldés
sans oublier le choix de mots pour
éviter de plomber l'atmosphère fait
exprès pour pas et pandémiques
je parlais de l'époque dans laquelle on
est et on vit à mama des moments
troubles et parfois plus j'essaie
d'amener mes blagues comme ça pour pas
qu'elle ait jetteront d'image de deux
malades
marc qualité parce que on est en ce
moment l'équipe du bye bye
elle promet tout de même des gags mort
dans la société compliqué en ce moment
donc c'est certain qu'ils gens qui m'ont
trouvé ça tu es sketch qu'à mon époque
le souhait demeure malgré tout de créer
un moment de réjouissance pour tous ce
soir pour vous parce que face au marasme
de 2020 le rire est peut être l'armé
ultime pour garder espoir ici valérie
michaela bayne radio canada montréal